[Applaudissements]
je suis si ça qu il fait beau langage et
j'ai fêté joyeusement mais 52 ans en
octobre dernier il est encore sonné ça
veut dire bros ma grand mère disait
toujours qu'on avait choisi ce prénom
parce qu'il est spécial avec du recul je
me dis qu'elle avait certainement des
visions nous sommes ici yvette et moi si
sakho pour partager avec vous notre
stratégie gagnante face à l'adversité
pour résister aux événements négatifs
extérieur au choc
nous avons constitué un cinq majeur
ce cinq majeur pour aller de l'avant ce
sont de solides appuis qui donne du sens
aux mots réception acquisition
expression conviction évolution
c'est ce mode de fonctionnement là qui
nous a permis durant plus de vingt ans
de décrocher plusieurs palmarès avec
différentes équipes et notre compagnon
de route
ce ballon orange ces titres ont nourri
mon ego pendant de longues années
calmant mémo intérieur mois la petite
fille ignoré par son géniteur
abandonné par sa mère voilà j'ai une
fille dotée de deux prénoms hors norme
qui ne trouvait pas sa place sauf dans
un gymnase moelle adultes dotés d'une
batterie auto chargeable et qui courait
toujours
après les succès et les défis à cette
époque je ne m'arrête pas pour
comprendre pourquoi je cours toujours
après les défis et les challenges
car en fait c'est victoire me grise
enfin j'étais ou plus exactement
yvette mon double gagnant était devenu
quelqu'un d'important pour les autres la
capitaine d'équipé qui motive qui fédère
qui protège ses copines de jeu comme une
mère protège ses ouailles la capitaine
qui va aux interviews journal l'équipe
et la vie fils ilan y passe
avec lui il est a appris à être pugnace
à intégrer minitieusement dans son
disque dur
l'audace le goût de l'effort à être
libre à agir plutôt que subir
j'avoue ça ne facilite pas toujours un
vous dis hein
les relations avec les autres avec un
tempérament pareil on l'a souvent dit
d'yvette et deux mois que nous avions un
sale caractère que nous étions ingérable
à cela moi si sakho je réponds que j'ai
un fort tempérament et que je suis
gérable si le cadre qu'on me propose
correspond à ma vraie nature
bonjour en gagne et un autre on perd ça
fait partie du jeu ah oui mais non il
fait l aime pas à cette règle en est les
compétitrices performeur c'est une
winner dans l'âme elle analyse vite les
failles de l'adversaire
elle n'hésite pas à faire appel à de
l'aide pour renforcer ses acquis vont
l'apprendre de nouveau même si parfois
ça fait mal à 36 ans il va être décidé
de prendre sa retraite de sportifs
professionnels et elle s'efface pour
laisser sissako prendre ses marques dans
sa nouvelle vie de sportive retraités
je me souviens pu en fait des matches
perdus ou gagnés en fait ce qui me reste
c'est aventure humaine partagée celle
qui vous transcende celle qui vous fait
vivre des émotions fortes
oui je construis ma vie avec passion
j'avoue et performance mais mes
performances individuelles monde vraie
valeur que dans le collectif grâce aux
passes décisives de mes coéquipières
heures dans la vie c'est comme dans un
match de basket et des moments il ya des
pauses forcées
les coups de sifflet de l arbitre des
temps morts et puis d entre eux deux ah
oui savez vous ce qu'est un entre deux
eaux basket c'est à ce moment là que la
partie commence chaque équipe envoie son
atout son colosse techniciens habitués à
réussir cet exercice réussir si vous
laisse deviner qui s'y colle mais pas
cette fois ci c'est entre deux dans la
vie me terrasse melesse lit deux pieds
collés au sol sans impulsion le nom de
mouleur versèrent et cancer et il
revient trois fois à force de coller aux
croyances des autres voleurs
correspondre exactement la demande
externe à ce que je représente pour les
autres oui capitaine keith a comme celle
sur qui on peut compter dans les moments
chauds patate dans les moments de crise
d'ego coach sissako celle qui transmet
ses connaissances et ses compétences
oui grande soeur admirer fille adoptive
tellement reconnaissante d'être aimé
qu'à l'aube il s'est mis le cancer c'est
un méga incendie qui ravage tout sur son
passage
mes croyances brûlé mes souvenirs brûlés
le plaisir boulet et mes amours bruits
aussi aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
je suis en feu trop d'eau pour
l'éteindre
j'ai mal partout
je ne tiens plus debout mes muscles
fonde trop vite je suis maigre 1
tellement maigre un vrai zombie de
fruits leur fatigue tellement fatiguée
c'est juste envie d'aller retrouver mes
frères là où mes deux frères emportés
par le kram
si mal j'ai tellement mal épée de
damoclès foutu somme dont une ligne chat
c'est qu'une envie je n'ai plus qu'une
envie c'est de fermer les yeux alors
c'est là qu'il fait la battante se
réveille et je l'entends me dire hey big
mama bâ warriors ma championne ce n'est
pas le moment de flancher
là on est dans du dur championnats du
monde ou aux jeux olympiques tu choisis
mais vite car dans le jeu présents soit
tu vis pleinement
soit tu meurs pense à ce qui est
important pour toi si tu meurs qui va
s'occuper du petit tu dois encore la
compagnie vous avez encore plein de
choses à vivre ensemble et des petits
basketteurs commente-il devenir sentons
côte à l'est pense à tes soeurs et
neveux et nièces des amis items tous il
compte sur toi ils ont besoin de toi
allez je sais que c'est dur comme toi ma
belle
moi j'ai besoin de toi parce que je
t'aime ensemble on va aller la chercher
cette médaille la plus belle qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent
et dans ma douleur dans le brouillard de
la morphine en péridurale les paroles
d'yvette font écho en moi et derrière
sentant nelson mandela mon bouddha garde
la tête pointé au soleil les pieds en
mouvement ne te livre pas au désespoir
rejette la défaite et à mort ok ok ok ok
j'ai encore un peu de force
j'ai envie j'ai ensuite cette médaille
j'ai envie d'aller la chercher
je suis grande encore un peu musclé je
ne laisse pas abattre au fait avez-vous
déjà eu l'impression d'avoir été
programmé pour quelque chose
moi oui je vous expliquerai - oui alors
en 2005
voilà le premier mon premier adversaire
qui se rapproche je suis encore en forme
où chaque camp véloce il se rapproche je
le croise une première fois
j'accélère je le dépasse et je me dis
yes c'est bon oh non voilà le deuxième
qui prend le relais je dribble il se
rapproche et grâce aux solides écran
posé par les coéquipiers la blouse
blanche
je l'en roule et je lui met deux points
sur sa phase de crabes ignore faith
respire et j'admire les petites beauté
de la vie pas longtemps car en 2013
voilà le troisième pâti comme une
armoire à glace qui veut ma peau
et là il me marquer à la culotte et
défend white
je déteste ça onze mois de faith tout
fait de corps à corps il me coupe du je
m'étouffe et il va être là il est
vraiment temps il est vraiment temps de
sortir l'armé fatale
notre spécialité le rebond au basket
savez vous ce que c'est le rebond
en fait c'est le fait d'aller capter le
ballon après un tir manqué avant que
celui ci ne touche le sol pour être un
bon rebondeur
il ne suffit pas d'être en muscles et
non ils font plus maîtriser la technique
alors
c'est la position préférentielle
je suis prête pour le dernier combat
toutes mes forces
j'ai l'oeil du tigre il a pu écarter les
genoux un peu fléchi
je mets mes appuis
mes pieds entre eux lui tond soirée et
ma vie je pense mon bras au dessus du
sien des coudes en arrière et alors il
ne passe pour yvette et l'a deviné ce
tir réussi la troisième tentative
c'est la bonne et on dit yes victoire
la voilà la médaille olympique au pardon
eelv est notre médaille et ma vie c'est
ça ta reformé accepter la souffrance
comme la défaite alors amoureuse de la
vie
yvette ma meilleure copine et moi
sissako rappeler la brosse qui s'y
frotte s'y pique
hé bé nous avons décidé pour aller de
l'avant de nous appuyer sur notre cinq
majeur un s'accepter et s'estimer deux
laissé ses émotions et ses ressentis
s'exprimer moi j'ai décidé d'assouvir
une passion qui me font du bien
je réfute tout ce qui me fait du mal et
j'apprécie chaque jour chaque instant
comme le dernier
3 restez connecté aux autres avec audace
j'accueille chaque nouveauté chaque
nouvelle rencontre comme une nouvelle
opportunité pour nourrir ma curiosité et
continue de réaliser mes rêves
4 faut que je vous dise pour être ici
j'avais deux coaches de au moins pour
moi les pauvres
4 choisir ses mentors avec discernement
moi je sais que ma garde rapprochée est
en alerte et réactive et j'avance le
coeur plus léger
parce que j'ai confiance et enfin 5 g
pas les chevilles qui gonflent vous
promets croire en soi et en l'impossible
avec yvette mon double gagnant nous
avons 100 parce que nous avons confiance
en nous alors je vous demandais aviez
vous déjà eu l'impression d'être
programmé pour quelque chose et je vous
disais moi oui je crois que je suis né
pour être capitaine de ma vie de rebond
en rebond je suis le m veepee de ma vie
oui mvp
c'est le type qu'on donne aux meilleurs
joueurs d'un match ou d'une compétition
alors la presse cinq majeur je voudrais
vous dire mesdames et messieurs que
rebondir
c'est préparer sa résidence j'aimerais
vous faire une dernière passe décisive
en vous posant la question suivante avez
vous en créez vos appuis
ma médaille olympique aussi
où
tous habitent
pendant excusez moi alors ça c'est à ce
moment là qu'on sent qu'on vieillit à 52
ans j'ai insistons qui a 16 ans et qui
poursuit le chemin du haut niveau il
vient de me dire et maman elle un peu
molle tapas ou non de chou sport
[Musique]
merci